It is
a local puréed chard
that is topped with poached crab
and then splashed with
a really yummy ramp dressing.
I love yummy ramps.
Oh, I love, um, chards.
We like to
say here that ramp
is the truffle
of onions.
(chuckles)
It's a dumb little joke.
(together)
We like to say that, too.
(chuckles)
That's funny.
Now have you guys
been to Octavia before?
No, we are
poppin' our cherry.
Wow.
(chuckles)
Well, you just let me
do the driving.
I'm gonna
take excellent care
of you guys
tonight.
Okay.
Once again...
je m'appelle John,
and bonne anniversaire.
Oh, thank you.
Wow.
He's tall
and he's bilingual?
I'm short and I can't
speak English good.
He probably has
a French press
and one of those things
that in the bathroom
you clean
your butthole with.
Oh, a bidet.
A bidet.
(sighs)
He's so classy.
Totally.
You're bad-mouthing me
to Anton now?
You cannot
find one minute
to go pick my sister up
at the airport?
Tell her fat
ass to flag down a cab
like a person.
My sister is
an ex-junkie, John, okay?
She needs someone to
pick her up,
she can't be unsupervised.
Jesus Christ,
she's a grown woman.
She can't be babysat
her whole life, Cheryl.
Well, thank you so much
for the support.
Support? Tell her to give
back the laptop she stole.
She never stole that!
You have no proof that she--
Are you kidding me?
You need to wake up.
What? You're crazy.
I don't know that she gave
us bedbugs for sure,
but I'm
pretty damn positive.
This is why I wanted
you to go to Al Anon.
Salmon, we got onion rings,
we got a gumbo.
How's the steak doing?